♪ ♪
- ♪ WELL, TONIGHT
WE GONNA PARTY ♪
♪ TILL THE PARTY DON'T STOP ♪
♪ AND THE PARTY DON'T STOP ♪
♪ BECAUSE IT
KEEPS ON GOING NONSTOP ♪
♪ GONNA PARTY ALL NIGHT ♪
♪ GONNA KEEP
THIS PARTY GOING ♪
♪ 'CAUSE THE PARTY
WON'T STOP ♪
♪ IT'S BEEN TWO STRAIGHT DAYS
AND THE PARTY'S STILL GOING ♪
♪ TWO, THREE, FOUR, FIVE,
SIX, SEVEN DAYS ♪
♪ TILL IT'S FRIDAY AGAIN
AND THE PARTY KEEPS GOING ♪
♪ PARTY ALL NIGHT
'CAUSE IT'S AN ALL-NIGHT PARTY ♪
♪ FRIDAY NIGHT, 9:00 P.M. ♪
♪ HOP IN THE CAR,
CALL MY FRIENDS ♪
♪ DRINKS IN THE BACK,
GIRLS UP FRONT ♪
♪ WE'RE GOING TO A PARTY,
SENDING TEXTS ♪
♪ CELL PHONE RINGS,
iPAD, FACEBOOK, PARTY TIME ♪
♪ SKIN-TIGHT JEANS,
FRIDAY NIGHT ♪
♪ DANCE, DANCE, DANCE ♪
♪ 'CAUSE TONIGHT WE GOIN' OUT
AND WE AIN'T COMIN' BACK ♪
♪ 'CAUSE THE PARTY WON'T STOP
AND WE'LL GO ALL NIGHT ♪
♪ FRIDAY NIGHT, EVERY NIGHT,
THE PARTY'S GOING DOWN ♪
♪ DOWN, DOWN, DOWN, DOWN,
DOWN, DOWN, DOWN, DOWN, DOWN ♪
♪ NEW YORK CITY,
L.A., CHICAGO ♪
♪ HOUSTON, PHILLY,
SAN DIEGO ♪
♪ PHOENIX, AUSTIN,
FORT WORTH, BOSTON ♪
♪ MEMPHIS, DENVER,
PORTLAND, VEGAS ♪
[muffled music continues]
♪ ...LUBBOCK, DURHAM,
SALEM, DAYTON ♪
♪ CITIES, CITIES,
CITIES, CITIES ♪
♪ 'CAUSE TONIGHT WE GOING OUT
AND WE AIN'T COMIN' BACK ♪
♪ 'CAUSE THE PARTY WON'T STOP
AND WE'LL GO ALL NIGHT ♪
♪ FRIDAY NIGHT, EVERY NIGHT,
THE PARTY'S GOING DOWN ♪
♪ DOWN, DOWN, DOWN, DOWN,
DOWN, DOWN, DOWN, DOWN, DOWN ♪
♪ NEW YORK CITY,
L.A., CHICAGO ♪
♪ HOUSTON, PHILLY,
SAN DIEGO ♪
♪ PHOENIX, AUSTIN,
FORT WORTH, BOSTON ♪
♪ MEMPHIS, DENVER,
PORTLAND, VEGAS ♪
♪ TUCSON, FRESNO,
AKRON, TAMPA ♪
♪ PITTSBURGH, NEWARK,
PLANO, LINCOLN ♪
♪ LUBBOCK, DURHAM,
SALEM, DAYTON ♪
♪ CITIES, CITIES,
CITIES, CITIES ♪
♪ CITIES! ♪
♪ YEAH, WE'RE GONNA
KEEP IT GOING ♪
♪ TILL THE BREAK OF
BREAK OF DAWN ♪
♪ THEN WE'LL JUST
KEEP PARTYING ALL DAY LONG ♪
♪ HOT GIRLS, MUSIC, DANCING,
AND BIKINIS AND HEADPHONES ♪
♪ PARTY, PARTY, PARTY, PARTY,
PARTY, PARTY, PARTY, PARTY ♪
♪ ♪
♪ SO TONIGHT WE'RE GONNA PARTY
TILL THE PARTY DON'T STOP ♪